et il n'y aura pas de chasse aux
sorcières que les partisans du rhdp se
rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre pour les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près des îles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gauche courtise les écolos jean luc
mélenchon et yannick jadot ensemble dans
le marais poitevin aujourd'hui les
leaders écologistes et de la france en
soumises font cause commune pour la
préservation de l'eau dans les deux
sèvres
alors que plusieurs personnalités
appellent à une gauche unie pour 2022
c'est
un premier bilan pour le premier
ministre jean castex 100 jours au
pouvoir sans vraiment convaincre les
français alors que le virus se propage
les bombardements continus dans le
nagorny karabakh malgré le cessez le feu
l'azerbaïdjan accuse l'arménie d'avoir
tué près d'une dizaine de civils dans la
taille d'un quartier résidentiel dans la
deuxième ville du pays
accusation qualifiée de mensonge par
l'arménie la capitale de la région du
haut karabagh a été de nouveau la cible
de frappes aériennes la nuit dernière la
russie et la turquie appelle les
belligérants au strict respect de toutes
les dispositions de la trêve signée
avant-hier
à 23 jours de l'élection présidentielle
aux états unis donald trump s'offre un
meeting électoral à la maison blanche
avant de reprendre sa tournée dès demain
en floride pour sa première allocution
publique six jours après sa sortie de
l'hôpital
le président a de nouveau minimisé la
gravité de l'épidémie
ces médecins firma qui n'est plus
contagieux
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir une image assez
rare pour que l'on en parle jean luc
mélenchon et yannick jadot dans le même
bateau au secours de l'eau dans le
marais poitevin
pour compléter le tableau il y allait
même josé bové gauche écologiste main
dans la main aux côtés des opposants à
la construction de réservoirs de
substitution sur le bassin de la sèvre
près de niort
un nouveau pas vers l'union de la gauche
prônée par plusieurs personnalités pour
la présidentielle de 2000 22
une union qui ne pourra se faire sans
les écologistes ou sans mettre en ouvre
en avant l'écologie est la france a
soumises à de fait revu ses logos
ecoutez jean luc mélenchon il est
question que notre prochaine convention
nationale
on adopte comme symboles autour de notre
fille la goutte d'eau qui serait un peu
la description à la faute ce qu est la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
et puis qui centralise la question de
l'eau parce qu'on pense que c'est une
question qui va devenir transversale
pour l'instant au niveau des décideurs
c'est pas quelque chose de conflit mais
demain vous pourrez plus prendre une
seule décision sans que quelqu'un soit
obligé de dire si oui ou non il y aura
l'eau pour le faire et alors que la
gauche tente de se ressouder ce dimanche
marque un premier bilan pour l'exécutif
cela fait 100 jours qu emmanuel macron a
nommé jean castex au poste de premier
ministre et monsieur d confinement n'a
pas vraiment réussi à convaincre les
français alors que la propagation du
virus en france bat des records est
16100 contamination ces dernières 24
heures une propagation qui semble
totalement échappé à l'exécutif mais dit
escaffit et quentin mauclair choisi par
emmanuel macron jean castex arrive au
début de l'été à matignon dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire et
économique sans précédent un choix qui
tranche avec les profils généralement
retenues pour un tel poste
une image d'élu local et un accent du
sud-ouest qui éclipse presque le reste
de son cv emmanuel macron veut un
premier ministre proche des français au
capital sympathie intact après des mois
de crise entre gilet jaune grève des
transports et couacs à répétition au
sein de la majorité
mais après trois mois à la tête du cou
heureusement qu'en est il de cette
stratégie jean castex a réalisé plus
d'une quarantaine de déplacement ses
principales missions la relance
économique et la sécurité
mais les français l'attendaient surtout
sur la crise sanitaire comme le 11
septembre dernier
l'opinion s'attendait à de grandes
annonces de sa part il n'en a finalement
rien été
oui le virus est là pour quelques mois
encore et nous devons réussir à vivre
avec lui sans nous laisser entraîner à
nouveau dans une logique de confinement
généralisée
certains observateurs notent ray chez
jean castex un problème d'actions et à
un manque de visibilité sur les
chantiers qu'il engage d'après un récent
sondage ifop fiducial pour paris match
42% des français ont une opinion
favorable du premier ministre soit une
baisse de cinq points par rapport au
mois dernier un manque flagrant
d'adhésion donc mais également un
capital sympathie en chute libre
c'est une première partie de mandat qui
est assez flou difficile et j'ai un
petit peu du mal moi même amoureux à m'y
retrouver
on l'entend mais il se démarque pas
autant que les heures philippe mais
malgré tout je pense que ils font faire
le gouvernement fait un peu ce qu'il
peut pour régler la crise
on pensait que le déconfinement ça
s'était plutôt bien passé et là qui a
beaucoup de flottement en septembre moi
je travail dans l'éducation nationale je
comprend rien à ces changements et c'est
comme si ce n'était pas piloté en fait à
l'assemblée nationale aussi jean castex
et mise à l'épreuve par ses pairs des
membres du gouvernement parle de
capacité oratoire limité lors de ses
interventions dans l'hémicycle certains
pointent du doigt sa difficulté à
réaliser les arbitrages entre les
différents ministres nous avons
d'exclure une nouvelle catégorie de
tests dits antigénique 100 jours sans
convaincre
même au sein de la majorité des doutes
commencent à s'immiscer
mais il n'ya pas que jean castex qui
décroche dans les sondages la cote de
confiance des manuels macron a encore
chuté ce mois ci pour atteindre son
niveau le plus bas depuis le début de la
pandémie et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct avec notre éditorialiste
politique
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors pourquoi ça
prend pas avec jean castex moins d'un
français sur deux lui fais confiance
ça prend pas parce que il ne suffit pas
d'avoir un accent une tête bonhomme et
puis et puis de voyager 1 de faire le
touriste dans son propre pays pour être
populaire on pourrait être proche des
français
le problème des modèles maquereau en
général de ce gouvernement en
particulier c'est que les technocrates
font confiance aux technocrates jean
castex est un énarque il a été
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
sous nicolas sarkozy
et il n'est pas politique au sens
politique du terme c'est à dire que il
est pas très bon pour la communication
on se rappelle de ce qu'il avait dit sur
ce top cow vide que lui même ne l'avait
pas téléchargé qu'il n'en voyait pas
l'intérêt parce qu'il ne prenait pas le
métro ce genre de couac
quand on est premier ministre c'est
inacceptable c'est quelque chose que les
français entendent voix et dans un
gouvernement où la communication prime
parce que derrière vous avez des très
bons à la communication vous avez
quelqu'un comme marlène schiappa où
monsieur darmana à l'intérieur
le président emmanuel macron qui fait
tout pour la comme lui n'est pas très
bon en communication et on voit la
différence finalement et derrière
malheureusement comme il n'est pas aidé
par cette crise du coronavirus et bien
qu'on ne voit pas les actions on a
l'impression que finalement il n'existe
pas il ne prime pas et il ne trouve pas
sa place dans ce gouvernement de de
l'image et c'est surtout qu'il avait
l'image de monsieur déconfinement alors
que aujourd'hui on le voit la
propagation du virus c'est assez
exponentielle 16000 son cas ces
dernières 24 heures on a une moyenne de
17 mille et c'est en progression
constante cette dichotomie entre l'avant
et l'après lui est néfaste également
complètement jean castex était comme
vous le disiez monsieur déconfinement
sauf qu'il s'est appuyé sur le cabinet
bain and company qui avait expliqué
comment faire des tests alors on a vu un
le fiasco des tests avant cela on avait
le fiasco des masques et puis on a eu ce
déconfinement de l'été où on a dit au
français finalement à les hisser les
vacances faites ce que vous voulez la
rentrée se passera à peu près bien on
est on verra on gérera à vue mais un
virus comme celui ci ça ne se gère pas
bu ça se planifie alors on a fait le
commissariat au plan
avec monsieur bayrou mais ça ne suffit
pas et jean castex qui a été responsable
des confinement est responsable de la
déconfiture actuelle c'est à dire que on
voit bien que ça ne marche pas jean
michel blanquer air qui devait gérer la
rentrée n'a rien géré du tout
aujourd'hui les principaux foyers de
contamination sont dans les écoles et
les facultés or aucune mesure
particulière n'a été prise ni en amont
ni maintenant qu'on voit que la crise
est à nos portes et on met encore une
fois le fardeau de cette crise sur les
français et sur les soignants alors oui
les français est bien dans les sondages
ont bien compris qu'il ne fallait pas
faire confiance à monsieur castex aux
autres et une chute dans les sondages
jusqu'à 28% -2 30% parce que on voit
bien que personne ne gère et c'est ça
qui est grave il est premier ministre
dont on attend de lui des choix des
arbitrages et un gouvernement qui
fonctionne qui prend des choix qui lui
qui prend des des actions hors les
actions ne suivent pas et ça ça se voit
malgré les déplacements à mieux à
répétition de jean castex mais qui les
prend juste
on sait ses décisions sur les actions
alexis poulain on sait que jean castex
un directeur de cabinet qui lui a été
imposée par l'elysée
c'est plus comme avec edouard philippe
finalement jean castex elle n'a t-il pas
les mains liées
mais complètement et c'est bien tout le
problème de ce gouvernement qui n'est
qu'un gouvernement d'acteur tout se
passe à l'elysée dans la tête des
malades macron avec alexis colère qui a
deux ou trois décident à peu près de
tout cette mise en scène finalement
arrive à sa fin parce que ce n'est pas
possible
a man il faut faire confiance aux autres
il faut travailler en équipe regardez
c'est la même chose pour eric
dupond-moretti il n'a pas pu choisir ses
collaborateurs au sein de son ministère
est partout c'est la même chose donc on
ne peut pas continuer comme ça c'est à
dire que la politique de l'homme sol de
la toute-puissance napoléonienne ça ne
marche pas au 21e siècle avec une crise
de l'ampleur du coronavirus il faut
faire confiance aux équipes
il faut libérer les énergies c'est
pourtant le message que voudrait faire
passer manuel macron mais non il est
dans le contrôle total et on voit bien
que jean castex est simplement là pour
s'effacer derrière la toute puissance du
roi parce que dès qu'une annonce
importante est à faire
le séparatisme et bien c'est tes modèles
mâcon qui va prendre la parole
dès qu'une noix importante va être mis
en place c'est encore le président qui
va se mettre en avant
donc jean castex n'est là que pour une
chose prendre les coups et se taire
alors il le fait très bien sauf que les
français n'aiment pas ça on aimerait
aussi un premier ministre qui lui aussi
travaille s'oppose au président parfois
quand c'est nécessaire et organise la
réponse à la crise du grenat virus qui
s'oppose au président c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi qu edouard philippe a été
écartée on est à quelques mois
maintenant de l'élection présidentielle
il va falloir que ça dure comme ça sans
faire de vagues jusqu'à 2022 c'est la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron alors si
c'est la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
elle est perdante parce que derrière ce
premier ministre inexistant c'est lui au
final qui prendra finalement les coûts
parce qu'on va bien comprendre où est la
responsabilité ou l organisation ou la d
re la désorganisation du moins c'est
donc avoir un ministre qui agit
c'est aussi montrer que le gouvernement
est bien était organisée et peut faire
des choses là on a l'impression d'une
incapacité totale et du gouvernement et
de l'exécutif avec en plus une assemblée
nationale où là les troupes dans marche
sont en train de se déliter
littéralement c'est à dire que
vous avez une fronde interne qui ne dit
pas son nom des gens qui ont déjà créé
leur groupe qui sont partis donc la
majorité est très faible et est le
gouvernement est lui aussi très faibles
et tout tient sur les épaules des
malades mâcon qui semble bien faible et
bien seul aussi à l'elysée
l'autre handicap de jean castex et
d'avoir eu un un prédécesseur finalement
qui est parti avec une cote de
popularité plutôt hot
oui alors la cote de popularité c'est
une chose edouard philippe a
effectivement organisé le premier
confinement puis est parti en disant que
les choses étaient faites
s'il était premier ministre aujourd'hui
ils prendraient tous les cryptes toutes
les critiques que prend jean castex
également donc il a su s'effacer et
partir au bon moment sachant qu'il avait
un point de chute à la mairie du havre
il est aussi je pense mis de côté 1
paraît mal mâcon je ne pense pas que les
deux hommes soient fâchés pour dire et
bien en 2022 6ème les maquereaux n'était
pas en capacité de se présenter parce
qu'on ne sait pas dans quel état sera le
pays d'ici deux ans et bien edouard
philippe est mis à l'abri un peu mieux
au congélateur en attendant on le
sortira tel hibernatus en disant vous
l'aimiez bien et bien le voici tel que
vous vous rappeliez de lui il est
capable peut-être de répondre à vos
attentes
en 2022 donc c'est un peu un joker c'est
quelqu'un qui attend son tour
et c'est pour ça qu'il a été je pense
mis de côté au bon moment parce
qu'aujourd'hui jean castex a le plus
difficile à faire c'est à dire gérer
cette crise relancer une économie
moribonde et puis et puis on ne sait pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'incertitude
qui prime et certainement pas la
planification merci beaucoup alexis
poulain d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur ces france ce soir
et alors que jean castex poursuit
actuellement une tournée des villes
consacrée à la sécurité un commissariat
était attaquée violemment la nuit
dernière en banlieue parisienne une
quarantaine d'individus armés de barres
de fer ont tenté de s'en prendre aux
policiers de champigny sur marne
il n'y a pas eu de blessés mais pendant
près d'une heure vous le voyez le
bâtiment a été la cible d'une pluie de
jets de mortier une porte vitrée et des
véhicules de fonction ont été dégradés
écouter la présidente de la région
ile-de-france et du ministre de
l'intérieur
il est évident que le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas à champigny devrait police
municipale qui puisse assurer une
relation entre entre les habitants et
les forces de sécurité
c'est un manque criant c'est un manque
criant les petits caïds n'impressionne
personne et ne décourageront pas notre
travail de lutte contre les stupéfiants
heureusement aucun blessé dans
l'agression visant le commissariat de
champigny cette nuit soutien total à nos
policiers qui font un travail difficile
les bombardements continus dans le
nagorny karabakh malgré le cessez le feu
l'azerbaïdjan qui accuse l'arménie
d'avoir tué près d'une dizaine de civils
dans l'attaqué d'un quartier résidentiel
dans la deuxième ville du pays
accusation qualifiée de mensonge par
l'arménie la capitale de la région du
haut karabagh a de nouveau été la cible
de frappes aériennes la nuit dernière la
russie et la turquie appelle les
belligérants au strict respect de la
trêve signée avant-hier françois xavier
lambert
dans les rues de stepanakert le calme
est revenu seuls les impacts de balles
et les voitures détruites rappelle la
très fragile entre les forces du haut
karabagh et l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
le cessez le feu entre les deux camps
négocier à moscou semble globalement
appliquée dans la république
autoproclamée
une situation plus calme confirmée par
le président du territoire lors d'un
point presse
ce dernier en a profité pour accuser
israël de vendre des armes à
l'azerbaïdjan
si le gouvernement israélien a dit qu'il
n'était pas au courant c'est faux ils
sont au courant on continue de fournir
ces drones
les autorités israéliennes sont
responsables de ce génocide
mais si la situation semble se calmer
dans le haut-karabagh la guerre se
déplace dans d'autres zones
durant la nuit des frappes ont détruit
un bâtiment où se trouvaient des civils
dans la ville de ganja la deuxième
d'azerbaidjan neuf civils auraient perdu
la vie selon les autorités
azerbaïdjanaises
le président ilham alief accusent les
forces du haut karabagh d'avoir mené ces
bombardements avec le soutien de
l'arménie
l'arménie a violé de manière flagrante
l'accord de cessez le feu et a lancé une
attaque au missile contre des habitants
innocents de la ville de grunge à il
s'agit d'un crime de guerre et d'une
violation flagrante des conventions de
genève
les accusations de bakou sont rejetées
par les autorités du haut karabagh qui
démentent tout bombardement
face à ces violences les habitants de
gandja font part de leur colère
qu'elle crève nous connaissons très bien
ces arméniens
nous savons comment ils se comportent
ils ont deux visages il manque
totalement d'honneur on peut même pas
les appeler des êtres humains
ce sont des barbares ce ne sont pas des
êtres humains
si vous avez une guerre c'est avec des
soldats et nous sommes des civils
nous dormirons la nuit les combats entre
les forces azerbaïdjanaises et celle du
haut karabagh ou pour l'instant fait
près de 500 morts
au bilan qui pourrait être en réalité
beaucoup plus lourd chacun des deux
camps revendiquent avoir tué des
milliers de soldats adverses et voyez ce
qu'en dit à pierre emmanuel thomas ni
les consultants en géopolitique et
fondateur de re continent les etats unis
l'otan et l'union européenne craignent
en réalité une mise en danger de l'homme
du corridor énergétique sud parce qu'il
ya le gaz et le pétrole qui passe par
dessus relaxe azerbaïdjan géorgie
turquie est donc cet axe est une
alternative à l'importation de gaz et de
pétrole russe
il y à certains acteurs pro turc e et
compte qu'ils sont atlantis et qui vise
la russie qui aimerait bien faire entrer
la turquie dans les négociations et qui
considèrent que le groupe de minsk comme
obsolète pour que la turquie joue le
rôle de contrepoids la russie mais
évidemment je pense que le meilleur que
l'on puisse arriver c'est une à nouveau
un conflit gelé dans le meilleur des cas
et à l'avenir il n'y aura pas de
solution sans une nouvelle architecture
européenne de sécurité qui avait été
proposé par la france d'ailleurs
tant qu'ils y arrivent alité entre
turquie russie et turquie et occident
notamment les états unis qui essaient de
repousser la thur la russie dans ses
terres continentales au moyen de la
déstabilisation de l'étranger proche
il n'y a pas d'espoir pour régler tous
ces conflits gelés dans l'ex urss et
pour faire cesser les combats plusieurs
manifestations ont lieu dans le monde à
l'initiative principalement de la
communauté arménienne en argentine des
centaines de personnes vous voyez se
sont rassemblés devant les ambassades
turques et azéri de la capitale des
membres de la communauté arménienne en
particulier exigeait la paix dans cette
région disputée et puis aux etats unis
également c'est sur le golden gate
bridge que les membres de la diaspora
arménienne
ont protesté le message du comité
national arménien d'amérique de san
francisco dit en substance la plupart
des personnes présentes à la
manifestation sont les descendants des
survivants du génocide arménien
installée aux etats unis mais sage
indirectement adressé à la turquie à 23
jours de l'élection présidentielle aux
états unis donald trump s'offrent un
meeting électoral à la maison blanche
avant de reprendre sa tournée dès demain
en floride
et pour sa première allocution publique
six jours après sa sortie de l'hôpital
le président a minimisé la gravité de
l'épidémie
ses médecins ont affirmé aujourd'hui
qu'il n'était plus contagieux
valentin carpentier d'abord je vais très
bien je ne sais pas pour vous comment
vous allez tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
un retour au premier plan fracassant
plus d'une semaine après avoir été testé
positif aux copies de 19 donald trump
s'est offert une sortie publique ce
samedi soir surplombant une foule
amassée devant la maison blanche le
président américain relance sa campagne
et veut d'abord rassurer grâce à la
puissance de l'esprit américain plus que
toute autre chose
la science et la médecine devons
éradiquer le virus chinois une fois pour
toutes
nous allons nous en débarrasser dans le
monde entier vous voyez de grandes
flambées en europe de grandes flambées
au canada comme vous avez vu aujourd'hui
beaucoup de flamber mais le virus va
disparaître il est en train de
disparaître les vaccins vont aider et
les thérapies vont beaucoup aidé une
sortie étonnante est critiqué quatre
jours seulement après être sorti de
l'hôpital même si le médecin du
président américain a précisé qu'il
n'était plus contagieux
la maison blanche n'a pas divulgué le
résultat du dernier test de donald trump
impossible donc de savoir si ce dernier
est désormais négatif ou non ce soir je
suis heureux d'annoncer qu'en plus du
fait que le président remplit tous les
critères des cdc pour une cessation
sécurité d'isolement au regard des
standards actuellement reconnue il n'est
plus considéré comme risquant de
transmettre le virus à d'autres
personnes
cette sortie publique de donald trump
aux allures de meeting électoral était
la première d'une longue série
au plus bas dans les sondages le
milliardaire se rendra lundi en floride
mardi en pennsylvanie et mercredi dans
l'iowa des déplacements alors que le
président américain est au plus bas dans
les sondages avec seulement 42 %
d'intentions de vote pour s'en prendre à
son rival joe biden le président
américain a tenu à se défendre sur les
récents événements liés au mouvement
black light matters et je le dis j'ai
fait plus pour la communauté noire que
tout autre président depuis abraham
lincoln
je le dis personne ne peut être en
désaccord avec cela personne ne peut
être en désaccord et c'est vrai en marge
de ce discours un rassemblement pro
trump avait lieu devant la maison
blanche
un cortège organisé par un mouvement
conservateur qui encourage les électeurs
afro américain a quitté le parti
démocrate
une dernière ligne droite crucial attend
donald trump
avec près de 10 points de retard dans
les sondages le président américain a
fait part de son envie d'aller sur le
terrain
à trois semaines de l'élection
présidentielle et son adversaire
démocrate lui faisait campagne dans
l'état clé de pennsylvanie l'année
dernière et il a de nouveau critiqué la
gestion de la crise sanitaire de son
rival
écoutez joe biden plus de deux cent dix
mille personnes sont mortes comme cela a
été souligné
nous perdons entre 700 et 1000 personnes
par jour plus de 7 millions et demi
d'américains ont été touchés infectés et
ce n'est pas fini
175 175 mille cas ici même en
pennsylvanie près de 11 millions
d'emplois ont été perdus depuis le début
de cette crise
ils n'ont pas été retrouvés et
licenciements temporaires se sont
transformés en licenciement définitif
nous avons encore perdu 6 174 mille
emplois manufacturiers dans tout le pays
depuis le début de la crise et plus de
40000 emplois du secteur de la
production industrielle ici en
pennsylvanie la présidence preuve sera
la première présidence depuis hoover qui
finira par quitter son poste avec moins
d'emplois que lorsqu'il est entré en
fonction et alors que donald trump se
dit immuniser le virus progresse dans le
monde notamment en amérique latine le
brésil vient de franchir le cap des cent
cinquante mille morts et avec 7 millions
de cas dépistés l'inde est le deuxième
pays le plus contaminé après les états
unis
mais la mortalité y est officiellement
moins importante
voyez les explications de cyrielle boys
deuxième pays le plus peuplé au monde
avec 1,3 milliard d'habitants l'inde
enregistre une hausse des contaminations
et du nombre de décès un bilan qui
s'aggrave sans pour autant atteindre une
situation incontrôlable
compte tenu de la densité de population
indienne avec 53 morts par million
d'habitants
l'un d'eux semble s'en sortir plutôt
bien mais pour les experts ces chiffres
pourraient être faussés 70% de la
population vit en zone rurale où les
décès et surtout les causes de décès ne
sont généralement pas recensés notre
système insuffisant de surveillance des
décès oubli déjà de nombreux décès au
départ un décès sur cinq seulement est
enregistré avec une cause déterminé
plusieurs autres hypothèses sont émises
pour expliquer ces chiffres
parmi elles la relative jeunesse de la
population avec une moyenne d'âge de 29
ans selon un rapport de l'onu
une certaine immunité est également
évoqué des maladies infectieuses comme
la dengue particulièrement présentes sur
le territoire ont pu apporter des
anticorps naturels à la population des
habitants qui déplore néanmoins non
respect des mesures sanitaires dans un
pays qui a franchi la barre des 100000
morts
il est très regrettable que cent mille
décès a été signalé
le gouvernement fait son travail au
mieux mais c'est à la population de
prendre les précautions nécessaires et
nous voyons beaucoup de gens qui
continuent à se complaire dans l'idée de
ne pas porter de masque et de ne pas
maintenir de distance sociale
c'est mon premier jour de sortie après
environ six mois et c'est un peu tendu
parce que les gens ne suivent pas les
directives appropriées sur le co vide
en tant que citoyen indien
nous avons la responsabilité de nous
occuper de ces petites choses qui
peuvent faire diminuer les cas et pas
seulement de blâmer le gouvernement
mu l'indre est le troisième état le plus
touché en termes de morts après les
états unis et le brésil
des résultats qui interviennent alors
que le gouvernement indien continue de
lever les restrictions afin de relancer
l'économie d'un pays durement touché par
un confinement strict mis en place dès
le mois de mars
et voyez à présent l'analyse de jean luc
racine directeur de recherche au cnrs
dans certains états indiens les
autorités au départ ont classé en autre
cause les gens qui mouraient du coc vide
mais qu'ils avaient d'autres maladies la
vraie question c'est que personne ne
sait s'il faudrait multiplier les
chiffres par 2 par trois ou par 4
certains disent par cinq
mais même si on les x simple
j'observe que ce qui me paraît être un
critère plus significative que de dire
il ya 7 millions de cas parce que dans
les 7 millions de cas ces sept millions
de cas historique en réalité aujourd'hui
il ya à peu près un million de cas
toujours actif mais il est vrai que le
pourcentage de décès pour cent mille
habitants
même si on le multiplie par 5 on se
retrouverait avec des chiffres par
exemple le proches de ceux de la france
était encore inférieurs à ceux de la
grande bretagne
donc il ya non pas un mystère indien
mais en tout cas une incertitude qui est
aujourd'hui davantage reconnu qu' il y
encore quelques mois et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dans un peu plus de trente
minutes sincérité
[Musique]
je
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]